you do have your lovely lady with you
tonight as you get your own TV show I
mean what is her support meant to you
through all the ups and downs especially
now that you're killing it you have yeah
having a strong woman standing by your
side I mean we support each other and
all the Arts and earn Devers are so it's
beautiful to go through so many
different challenges in our lives and
have a partner that loves you through
all of it so by the way she look she
looks hot
I feel like she's getting younger and
I'm getting older so I'm like what she's
doing what are you gonna do I think it's
gonna be fine but I mean you know right
I think she will she seems cool but yeah
I mean two kids later 14 years dude you
have your own freakin TV show I know
super cool it's on Apple and it's on the
first streaming like it's it's big they
were selling the iPhone and I'm standing
there was like fur on and a fricking hog
splitter it's awesome look this shows
epic I would imagine that as you put all
the furs on and all that you got a
little bit of G ot flashbacks how did
that show prepare you for doing this one
there's a lot of shows that prepared me
for G ot and this is just a continuation
of you know I never got a fight on VOT
really I never got to have babies and
then grow old and be married and so this
is all the things I never got to
exercise so I feel like it was a
beautiful moment for this to be able to
happen as an actor is yeah so it's a lot
of things didn't really happen I was
just kind of like fell in love and then
I died I wanted more yeah absolutely
I can I can do more I can speak English
I can smile I mean you would have liked
to see call go through all that yeah
absolutely
could've been nice and some of those
battle scenes at the end I mean would he
and Danny still be together
oh hell yeah
know that you know that by the way we
heard your kids were at the press day
the other day I love what a family you
guys are have they seem G ot and Ave
seeing this show are they too young
no they're too young it's funny too
because DN y systems have the thing too
like we're going to watch tool together
and so like you know I'm still the
creator of Game of Thrones we're all
together and so very much family you get
so close so fast
yeah gotta ask you though about another
big project cuz you're not slowing down
the Aquaman sequel what can we expect
I'm just I'm really stoked at the fan
base and what we did with the movie and
just went into Warner Brothers in DC and
kind of said you know I have some ideas
and they love they love them and James
and everyone's just kind of like we're
all taking it in we're excited to
another one there gonna be a showdown
between you and Black Manta I think
there's a lot more in store on the lot
there's so many more levels so rather
still locked up this could be a lot it's
gonna be bad way bigger alright my last
question for you Zoey is Catwoman you've
been through this superhero world what
advice have you given her about like how
to handle the fandom she's about to
that's actually the first thing I said
so I was like your life is gonna change
because I've been hiding for about a
good solid 18 years and then all sudden
Aquaman happened in boom so yeah that's
the one thing I don't even know if I'm
prepared I'm just like be she's gonna be
huge
she's beautiful she's talented it's just
gonna be she's gonna kill it and people
are gonna be like well welcome to the
team baby last question for you you and
your beautiful wife were here together
tonight I'm sure she finds you
attractive every day but which of your
characters is she most into that's a
great question who did she like oh I
think probably drugs oh sure they're
like I do with that if any of the
costume oh ho yeah I could it's like the
pants II mean did I keep the pants yes I
can't look bad
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]